I'm going to start with congratulations
uh thank you you guys literally did the
impossible you made something that's
very respectful of Chadwick but also
keeping the franchise going introducing
all these new characters I I don't think
people realize the level of difficulty
in in making this film right
yeah I agree no it was tough I mean it's
you know uh it was already going to be
tough just trying to make a sequel to
the first film because of how it was
received and and how it sort of hit
people uh and then obviously got
Complicated by by Chad's passing and and
sort of our kind of human reactions to
that event and uh you know I think Ryan
uh figured out a way to sort of maybe do
the impossible which is to marry the
emotion of what was happening and and
and
art entertainment imitating life to a
degree but also delivering on the
promise of characters like Namor and
Nutella Khan and Riri Williams I mean
there's there's a lot of a lot of ideas
in the movie that don't feel like
they're in in conflict with each other
um and it hopefully makes for an epic
experience for people uh 100 so I have
some like speed round questions if you
will uh what is the status of this
Untitled wakanda series
yeah so look it uh because of the amount
of time and attention that went to this
film and frankly the ironheart show that
is that is probably not as far along as
people want it to be but there are
certainly great ideas that we're still
talking to Ryan about so we'll see how
far we can get with it what is the
status of Iron Heart in terms of is it
is it done filming is nearly complete I
think there they might be on their
second to last day if I'm not mistaken I
heard room and I want you to clarify I
heard rumors that originally at the end
of the credits of wakanda forever you
were going to have a a final credit
scene was that ever the case no actually
uh and I've heard those rumors too no
you know I think the subject matter of
the film was such that it it didn't feel
appropriate to have them like a stinger
you know what I mean much like uh end
game felt like an emotional experience
that you also didn't need like a Stinger
at the end of this this felt like we we
just wanted to tell the story as as it
was conceived without uh without an
added added bonus so unfortunately there
isn't end credits I think the mid-credit
scene is phenomenal yeah and perfect and
I am glad there's nothing at the end
yeah like you guys totally made the
right call um uh what were some of the
alternate titles that this film almost
was called yeah that's a good question
um there was a literally like a list of
hundreds
um that's what black panther 3 is for
that's right no and and you and you
start to as you're like like Kingdom of
the deep like you're like does it have
to be about Neymar and then we realized
that that wakanda forever felt right
because it's a story about
um
sort of Triumph through adversity it's a
story about Legacy it's a story about
persistence and wakanda forever says all
those things you know initially I would
say this at one point it was like oh
that feels like the title of the third
movie like where do you go from wakanda
Forever that feels like that's the end
but no it's it's actually it felt really
appropriate thematically to the story we
were trying to tell the mid-credit scene
is
phenomenal yep how early on did you know
that was going to be the scene pretty
early on I mean that was that was always
the end of the movie uh uh pretty much
since Chad's passing
um I think the first draft we gotta had
that in there
um and
and the notion of of the character
introduced in that scene actually
predated Chad's passing to be quite
honest we always like the idea that that
uh that uh oh yeah yeah I know what you
mean yeah so so
um
but it was repurposed kind of
thematically once Chad passed
um and hopefully feels like
um
renewal at it after a time of adversity
I'm curious about the strength of the
atlanteans on the bridge yeah because
they are
um they basically get their ass kicked
yeah I mean fatal blows and they get up
yeah how do you describe their powers
yeah we've talked a lot about that like
uh are they sort of super soldier-esque
do they you know
um I am a a bit of a nerd so I used to
play the Marvel heroes role-playing game
and you're like wait do they have like
body armor like do they have like a a 10
what
um but no we we sort of see them as sort
of super soldier level partially because
they live under the water so they're a
bit tougher their Skin's a bit tougher
um their bones probably are lighter but
their muscle density is increased so so
they are uh uh stronger than humans
certainly
um and we're able to withstand aqua's
otherwise killing Strokes
um much to her frustration
um
which I think makes them incredibly
formidable so so if and when we see them
again I think whoever comes across them
might be in some trouble I would agree
with that statement yeah um what is your
next Marvel project uh Captain America
New World Order and where are you in the
development we are in pre-production we
start shooting next spring oh yes I just
realized what this is all um
do you have a script that you guys are
super happy with uh we do we do can you
tease uh well look uh Sam Wilson's
Captain America he is going to bring his
own team to play and it's no secret that
you know Samuel Stearns is making his
return to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
uh uh which is fantastic because Tim
Blake Nelson is the best and uh Harrison
Ford is taking on the role of General
Thaddeus Thunderbolt Ross
um and and to see Sam Wilson and and
Thunderbolt Ross which if you remember
actually threw him in prison at the end
of Civil War because he violated the
sokovia Accords there's going to be some
natural Sparks there which I think are
gonna be really fun do you for see black
panther listen I know you the movie
hasn't even come out yet yeah but
obviously black panther is going to be a
huge part of these characters going to
be a huge part of the MCU going forward
yeah do you envision a black panther
three in the next three four years or do
you think this is going to be something
where the wakanda and the characters are
just sort of embedded into the rest of
the MCU that's a great question and and
to be honest and this is not me uh this
is this is not me trying to not answer
the question we really want to see how
audiences receive the film you know and
I think Ryan's really interested to see
how the film plays before we decide
there are certainly ideas we've floated
around of what a a third film could be
if we get to make it but but until the
movie comes out we we certainly we're a
bit superstitious in that way we don't
want to count our chickens uh because
you never know what's gonna happen this
is gonna be a monster hit like this
isn't even a debate like like I mean I
hope your current this movie is going to
be massive because it's so good and also
people people are gonna love it
um did you end up with a lot of deleted
scenes on this movie we ended up with
some deleted scenes yeah when you say
some I'm curious what that actually
means uh more than two less than ten uh
no there's some great stuff I mean uh I
would say every character ha every
character maybe not every character a
lot of characters have scenes that that
are great scenes that the movie just
couldn't bear it's already a relatively
long movie
um but uh and we wanted to make sure the
movie felt as focused as it could while
doing as much as it's doing
um but there are some deleted scenes
that are really cool how much of those
deleted scenes were like close to
completed or completed before being
removed ah
um
I think there's a spectrum there's some
there's some that sort of from the
director's cut didn't make it forward
there's some that we played with for a
long time and screened and screened
multiple times
um we're kind of notorious for tinkering
a lot in editorial and trying things and
Ryan by the way is as well uh so things
are in things are out what about this
over here
um so some are closer to completion some
are are pretty raw well my thing is that
with Disney plus and obviously you want
people to go to the streaming site yeah
at some point so how much are you guys
already talking about like look we can
do the Black Panther wakanda forever
Extended Cut and put it on Disney plus
yeah we you know we've typically
resisted that and I think we'll continue
to because we like to think we and the
filmmakers landed on on what the movie
should be so I don't know that we'll
ever assemble and I'll Never Say Never I
don't think we'll assemble into a longer
like director's cut but certainly I
think there's ways to get those scenes
out there in the world without building
an extended edition it's called
premiering on collider there you go you
know um what is the lat what is the one
scene that if you could put it back in
the movie like the thing that you the
last thing you cut out before picture
locking right I mean there's there's
certainly a scene
um
with Okoye
and IO after Okoye has been fired that's
really interesting
um
that again I think is incredibly
watchable
it just it just slowed the pace down of
the movie a little bit but uh you get to
see akoye react to sort of the new
general and you and you get to see what
she was planning to do before uh before
the events of of Namor and the telecon
coming to wakanda happened it's actually
pretty cool yeah anytime you want to
show it to me it literally send me a
text and I will respond there you go on
that note I'm just going to say congrats
it really is going to be a huge oh
thanks man I appreciate it